our lead national correspondent that's
david bagneau is doing double duty for
us this morning he also has a preview of
a report for this week's 48 hours
about a champion boxer who was feared
who was feared for his strength in the
ring christy martin is her name and she
told him about her experience with
domestic abuse
she made history as the first female
boxer to appear on the cover of sports
illustrated remember that cover
but in 2010 she was shot by her husband
she nearly died
here is david's report
this is the fight that made christy
martin a
worldwide sensation it was a 1996 event
headlined by mike tyson her nose
bloodied by the third round
christy stole the show and she won the
fight
that was the most profitable bloody nose
in boxing history
a month later she was on the cover of
sports illustrated
in all christie won 49 fights with her
sights
set on number 50. but behind the scenes
christy says her husband jim martin
who was also her boxing coach was
abusive
and controlling i keep thinking of the
people who will watch this
and say how does a woman who's so
powerful how is she not able to stand up
for herself at home
i know that people think that but i
didn't have that same type of
mental strength to overtake him
when christie finally tried to end the
marriage she says
jim went on the attack beating and
stabbing her he starts to beat me
bam bam he's beating my head and bam
just like that
the switch flipped i told him you cannot
kill me
then says prosecutor deborah bera he
stands over her
and shoots her in the chest
the bullet missed her heart by three
inches
jim martin would stand trial for
attempted murder but defense attorney
bill hancock says
it was christie who attacked jim the way
jim described it christie was extremely
aggressive
[Applause]
he was constantly afraid of physical
attacks by her prosecutors were worried
would the jury have doubts about the
match-up
she became famous beating the hell out
of people exactly so
it's pretty plausible that she might
beat the hell out of her husband
absolutely but bear says it's not that
simple i think it's a remarkable story
because
you have a world famous champion boxer
and she could still be in a domestic
violence relationship
because that isn't about physical
strength
it's about mental abuse but you can
always survive it what would the jury
believe
christy says no matter what happened in
that courtroom she already won
when i got up off the floor and got out
of my house
that was my 50th win
boy david so many layers to that story
here's christy she's five
five she's shot in the chest number one
how does she survive that
and what does her ex-husband say happen
so it's incredible she survived gail she
told us she played dead on the floor
she hears him taking a shower so she
gets up
grabs the keys grabs the gun which by
the way was hers
and runs out the house flags down a
passerby who in the beginning is like
well wait a minute you said you're
shopping you're holding the gun wait
what's going on here
the husband says he was acting in
self-defense that
she was the aggressor that's what he
says you see it saturday night
he's acting in self-defense but he hops
in the shower a lot of questions there
thank you david